ciao ragazzi per tornatore una puntata
di cucina buttata in mezzo all 8 e mezza
ma tanto domani non mi devo svegliare
presto quindi questo cucina era
mezzanotte e mezza ha visto facendo
venire da comi tare che cosa mi dici è
katia cosa da dire niente un'arena di
poche parole una ragazza timida allora
dicevo adesso mi metterò a cucinare
perché ho appena visto una ricetta
pazzesca questa ricetta fondamentalmente
oddio è bello stare sdraiati mi sto
allenando ogni giorno 15 fiera spa la
scheda esperte la schiena a pezzi
questa ricetta dicevo è molto facile
perché si tratta di una torta salata in
tazza a microonde
ho fatto un sacco di torte in tazza ad
alcuni sono venute bene altre no ma non
ho mai fatto una torta e quindi ho
deciso di farla adesso che è mezzanotte
e mezza quasi io ho fatto capire questa
quarantena che quando stai a casa voi
sta e da qualsiasi parte io sono a new
york col fuso
guardate un libro formano di libri li
leggo quasi mettiamoci al lavoro come
dicevo non posso fare troppo casino
perché tardi ma in compenso guardate
indosso il pigiama
vabbè comunque in atto perché le
stagioni zando queste mani non lo so io
mazzone era stato china semplice passare
alle scene di questa ricetta per una
torta in tazza salata l'abbiamo presa su
blasting news.com che volete metterebbe
la watts emana ricetta voi molto
raramente questo è uno di quei casi nei
quali cerchiamo di capire se le ricette
che suggeriscono online effettivamente
funzionano no andiamo subito di cucina
per fare la torta salata in tazza avremo
bisogno di due punti 80 g di farina
doppio zero due uova media le ho trovate
bianche non ho mai cucinato nuovo bianco
che in realtà uguale all uovo quello che
un pochino di quel colore che non riesco
a capire perché sono daltonico volevo
troppo troppo troppo covar le 40 g di
burro che dovremmo fondere oppure se
volete olio di semi ma noi utilizzeremo
il burro fuso 2 cucchiaini di lievito
secco in polvere un cucchiaio di
pecorino grattugiato che l'ottica un
cucchiaio di parmigiano grattato che non
l'ho comprato perché mi sembra uno
schiaffo la miniserie dover comprare il
parmigiano solamente per fare una
ricetta metterò 2 cucchiai di pecorino
50 g di salame a dadini alzava caduto
ben 50 g di formaggio filante da mettere
anche questo a dadini sale odio che è
accaduto che porta sfiga cosa si fa
quando cadde il sale via questo
formaggio
oddio se fiuto accumulato qui via e
infine e partiamo subito col
procedimento quello che dice il sito è
da qualche tempo a questa parte
impazzano le mag che i che ovvero le
torte in tazza e fin qui ci siamo
divertenti simpatica e saporite e
pratiche opinabile più delle volte le
mie sembravano attacchi demo roy di
divertenti perché fanno delle battute
che ti fanno sganasciare la dr tematiche
io non sono se minaccia più ridere se
loro tipo teo mammucari e infine e
saporite e pratiche infatti la
particolarità di queste torte che
essendo monoporzione ognuno può
modificare la sua proprio piacimento
aggiungendo quel tocco in più che ne
renda personale ed unica mela stai
vendendo questa torta
permettetemi di parafrasare buttare
tutto in una tazza e viva inoltre con le
mag
quello che leggo io market è scritto nga
vabbè dicevo con le marche che
praticamente si ha la possibilità di
provare una torta nuova ogni giorno e
poi finire col trasportino in giro
specialmente durante la quarantena nel
quale non si fanno passi si può
addirittura provare una variante light
faccio prima a bere acqua da quella
tazza oggi parleremo di una golosissima
torta salata yacht e quando viene usato
il termine culoso perché golose sono le
persone io per esempio sono goloso di
dolci e non capisco come una torta possa
essere golosa di qualcosa e gustosa e
saporita
vabbè non voglio fare accademia della
crusca destra perché perché noi la
crusca in cucina non la usiamo alla dal
momento che le dosi di questa ma che mi
sembrano piuttosto abbondanti ho preso
la tazza più grande karaoke e cercherò
di sporcare il minor numero di roba
possibile all'interno di una terrina ci
dicono di aprire l'europa una come
servono più facilmente le strette le
uove bianche hanno il gusto leggermente
più si dice variabile di quelle di più
scure è pazzesco tutto quell'incontro
vice sbattiamo dell'interno di kunar
molto probabilmente sono tra le
pochissime cose stanno nello sbattute
durante questo isolamento ma beate loro
grande aggiungiamo a questo punto 80 g
di farina setacciata che ho deciso di
setacciare perché in realtà non ci vuole
troppa setacciarla e poi il grugnito
peggio di qualsiasi altra cosa al mondo
lo capisco per quante persone siano le
dosi ma prima sulla torta la sto
setacciando direttamente sulla bilancia
così ci metto pure meno tempo e non
c'era già tempo ho capito avremmo tutti
quanti si sentono biancaneve che fanno e
torte che lo faccio solamente perché ci
tengo troppo a questa rubrica 80
pazzesco grattugiamo dentro anche il
formaggio forse il paese per generare
come prima si faccia tornare aggiungiamo
due cucchiaini di lievito io li ho già
giunti ma non mi ero reso conto stesse
riprendendo attaccate che gli omessi
veramente bassi bassi bassi perché
passato abbondato invece quelli nei
video di davide microonde acerrimi
nemici e ti polare con le della l buono
non c'entra
sicché se troppo centro anche astinenza
e infine il burro fuso però me non mi va
a diffonderlo
idea seguite quello che sto per farlo
apprendo questa sotto l'ala metri
aprendo lei una piazza sopra evitando il
rifaccio susan e darà a questo punto mi
curo di buso 40 grammi di 35 grazie in
40 chiamo il compito e facciamolo
sciogliere a che cosa possiamo fare nel
frattempo fissarla
secondo una legge più fissi le cose più
si muovono lentamente quindi se nulla
fisserò sarà già finito aspettatemi on
line si stia sciogliendo troppo è un
pochino fuso fuso alzare i pochissimi
secondi quindi aggiungiamo a questo
punto il burro non sono stato inquadrato
piccolo un momento di approfondimento a
sapevate che il burro fuso non è solido
fine di questo momento di
approfondimento per le mie cugine stiamo
zitti
allora insieme ad amalgamare questa
parte di composto giusto alla fine di
questa danza propiziatoria dovreste
avere un composto super super morbido
questo punto pensiamo 50 grammi salame o
prosciutto cotto in sala nei cinque
grammi di formaggio filante in realtà
dicono anche di mettere la bieta verdure
se mi aggiungo altri 10 grammi a testa
quindi per il 60 in 60 per compensare
verdure allora ragazzi ho finito di
pesare gli ingredienti se non avete un
bilancio a casa più o meno è così meno
questo pezzi e tokyo mi serviva ci
voglio aggiungere altro giorni non ne va
della pancetta cui scusate ragazze tardi
sono stanco
tagliamo mentre i tagli o cubetti volevo
dirvi che nel frattempo abbiamo sporcato
solamente una ciotolina nella quale
abbiamo pensato tutti gli ingredienti e
la tazza e usato per metterci il burro
sciogliere la utilizzarono nuovamente e
poi metterci tutto quanto il composto
quindi il base o una tazza una ciotola
un coltello tagliere che altro sporcato
beh tutta la cucina in realtà alla fine
di tutto il procedimento i costi
ingredienti dovrebbero avere più o meno
questa faccia non questa questa
prendiamo la ciotola
a questo punto ci mettiamo dentro questa
volta mischiamo osservandolo da vicino
che schifo che schifo del cibo però che
schifo e prete giriamo amalgamiamo
incorporiamo ma che faccio è distribuito
in due tazze da latte per due persone e
cuocere 800 watt in forno a microonde
per due minuti 2 cancellate ok sto
sporcando anche un cucchiaio che adesso
sta per succedere la cosa che teniamo
tutte quante apriamo le formelle pronte
vogliamo di nuovo l'inquilino che non so
perché continuo a tornare lì piazziamo
una e due seguito seguite dito seguite
il dito 800 matta due minori in bocca al
lupo ragazze nel frattempo cerchiamo di
fare un pochino di l'ordine questo
prendiamo leggiamo per sbattiamo in
frigo lidi lato c'era una corda
prendiamo inquilina noi siamo qui il
coltello
siamo qui ha giocato altre rimetto a
posto su un cucchiaino da questo qui mi
fermo
cerchiamo di pericoloso mamma mia con
due ma io non sarei stato così bravo il
canino di tacco di carlo con una mano
sarà un po difficile lasciarlo stare
ok
[Musica]
e cruda ragazza come atomi 240 andiamo
veloci
1 non so perché se sei al 3 uova ancora
cioè la cabina sono ancora prima
celano
no
[Musica]
i ragazzi si riesce pure offrire tutto
quanto tempo che si dice l'ho finito o
che ufficialmente il braccio che tiene
la videocamera però è anche l'usato non
ho pulito attacco la sua virata tanto
per dire che c'è uno strano buon odore
nell'aria adesso qualcosa che sferico al
qua dentro
lasciamo la tensione di una forchetta
che facciamo una prova d'assaggio alle
svariate al momento dell'assaggio è il
118 e per girare tutto quanto ci ha
messo pochissimo in realtà ci si mette
mano come lo stesso non buone
prima di iniziare ad assaggiare ste
fornaci volevo ricordarvi che se volete
supportare questo canale potete
iscrivervi mettermi un pollice in su per
i e visto che sono anche solo e
soprattutto farmi sapere qua sotto quali
sono delle ricette vorreste vedere detto
ciò che direi di assaggiare consistenza
attimo quello di una spugna o
interessante non mi aspettavo
allora è molto buona ha colpa forse sarà
troppo in forno a microonde proprio
quella di un po più grande ora un po più
grande ecco l'unica posizione dire
ascolti ok più buona perché lo ha messo
più tempo a cosa si forse bisogna
tenerli tra i due minuti e mezzo
italia2 secondo me troppo poco per forse
potrebbe venire più morbida un pilot
tenuta 340 too much mamma ma nello
stesso castro mangia la sala all'altra
ciò la famiglia buona che prende le
parti molli e ancora più buona tenterà
di meno un consiglio mio chiediamo la
prossima domenica un'altra puntata di
voci amputata e martedì con il blogger